that's right there  right there's blood on that side it  already sings buried around there yeah  damage the cow booths will never go  through I hit it perfect you never let  go of your harpoon that's why once the  seal is shot or punctured it must be  pulled to the boat quickly or will sink  to the bottom  John's failure to harpoon this one is a  costly mistake sinka yeah straight down  although it is quite a bit challenging  with all the ice gun usually get for  sure shots were just a whole bunch of  rook or sleeping or relaxing in the Sun  with all the ice gun now we have to just  chase out some seals and hopefully shoot  them harpoon him and get him into the  boat without sinking them we've done it  before we could do it again